-Hey, guys. Welcome back to "The
Tonight Show: At Home Edition."
My name is Jimmy Fallon.
I want to thank you guys so much
for watching our show.
And we've gotten
such amazing feedback
from around -- not just
the country, but the world.
And so it really means
a lot to us
that you're choosing to watch us
to -- to make you laugh
and kind of give you a little
ease in the tense times.
Thank you very, very much.
We definitely got some --
some notice
from a couple corporations
that wanted to help us out
in raising money.
So I really want to thank --
State Farm is willing to --
Get ready for this, guys.
This is big news.
They're going to match
up to $100,000,
with all the money
going to Red Cross.
They're going to match this week
up to a hun--
that's $200,000 we can raise
this week.
So please donate
to right here --
redcross.org/statefarm.
Thank you, thank you, thank you
to our neighbors at State Farm
for doing that.
That means a lot to us,
and we'll be talking about this
this whole week
on our show tonight.
I hope everyone
who stayed at home had a --
Oh, hi, buddy.
Nice to see you.
We -- You can show what we did,
Frannie, right?
What did we do over the weekend?
Can we...?
We -- No, we --
we colored this in, didn't we?
-Yes.
-Now, Winnie,
did you color any of this?
-Yeah.
-This is our
market stand/lemonade stand
that took us four days to do.
I was just --
look at these colors.
I mean, are you kidding me?
And so I thought
what would be fun is that
we could use it as --
almost like a desk,
like Daddy's desk at work,
and I could read you some jokes.
Do you guys want to hear
some jokes?
-No. [ Laughs ]
-We have
an amazing show tonight.
Kim Kardashian West is my guest.
We'll be Zooming with her,
talking about her new
documentary airing on Oxygen
about criminal justice reform
and, also, all the money
she's giving
through her company SKIMS
to charity,
which is really awesome
that she's doing that.
Then we're gonna talk to
music superstar Jon Bon Jovi,
who is doing amazing stuff
with JBJSoulKitchen.org --
that is his charity
that he's talking about today.
We'll be talking to Jon
about that
and, also, his new song that
you can sing with him through.
You'll see later in the show.
Then we have great music
from OneRepublic.
I'm so happy
you guys did that for us.
Thank you so much, OneRepublic.
Brand-new song from them
from their home.
I thought
it would be kind of cool
to do some monologue jokes now,
so let's get going.
Here we go.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show:
At Home Edition."
Let's get to some news.
Well, guys,
in these crazy times,
Taco Bell announced that,
tomorrow,
they're offering every American
one free Doritos Locos Taco.
Experts are calling it
"not what we need during a
national toilet paper shortage."
[ Fireplace hissing softly ]
Love the nice hiss
of the gas fireplace.
[ Fireplace hissing softly ]
Meanwhile, over in Moscow,
a citywide quarantine
has been imposed
where everyone will be trapped
by a smart monitoring system,
and residents will need
permission to leave their homes,
or, as that's known in Russia,
Monday.
Some sports news --
the Wimbledon tennis tournament
is the next big sporting event
that will be canceled.
Don't worry --
if you still want to hear
men and women grunting all day,
just listen to the quarantined
couple next door who won't stop.
Earmuffs, you know.
Some business news --
as of Friday,
the videoconferencing
company Zoom
has valued
at more than $40 billion,
or roughly as much as Uber,
which makes sense,
since they're both places
where users have no idea
how to mute themselves.
Listen to this --
I heard that a lot of people
are doing virtual sessions
with their therapists,
but it's hard
because they can't talk
about their significant others.
When the doctor says,
"How's your relationship?"
you have to go,
"It's very good."
I saw that some people
have been posting
throwback photos of themselves
online.
Gets awkward when you comment,
"Wow, you looked
so young back then,"
and they're like,
"That was from two weeks ago."
This isn't good --
last night, a Dutch museum says
that a Vincent Van Gogh painting
was stolen.
Apparently, the security guard
tried stopping the thieves,
but he couldn't
get within six feet of them.
[ Rhythmic tapping ]
Listen to this --
according to a new study,
the majority
of medical marijuana
is stronger than it needs to be
for pain relief purposes.
You can read more
about the study
in the "Journal
of American Narc Physicians."
And finally, the movie
"Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles"
hit theaters 30 years ago today.
They all wore masks,
ate lots of pizza,
and were hidden away
from society.
So, basically,
we're all Ninja Turtles now.
Thank you very much.
That's our monologue
right there, everybody.
Hey, we want to check in
on our very good friend,
one of my best friends.
You know him -- you love him --
Steve Higgins.
So I got to check in on him
today.
He's doing great.
Here's Steve at home
with his family.
Higgins!
-Hey!
How's it going, man?
-Hey. I missed your face, dude.
How you doing, buddy?
You look great.
-Oh, so good.
Everything's good.
Everything's as good as can be.
-Where are you now?
Where -- Where exactly are you?
-We're -- We're at the house --
the boys and I and Ellen.
We're staying at the house.
And Anna's staying in the city,
nursing at Mount Sinai West.
-Oh, my.
-God bless her.
-How is she doing?
I love Anna so much.
I'm so proud of her, dude.
-She is thank-- She's just --
She says she's just exhausted
every night.
So she just comes home
and goes to sleep, goes back --
[Chuckling]
wakes up, goes back into work,
and she's on the front line,
so...
-She's on the front lines
for us, fighting for us.
Tell her I'm so proud of her,
please,
and give her my best...
-Oh, I will.
-...'cause I knew her when --
I used to call her
"Anna Banana."
She was 5 when I --
-Yeah.
[ Chuckling ] Exactly.
I mean, you did meet her
when she was 5 years old.
How crazy is that?
-And -- And you have your --
Are your sons there, as well?
-Yep,
all three of them are here.
And then Ellen's here, and we're
just at the -- at the house,
trying to kind of --
just staying quarantined.
But I tell you,
watching you and Frannie
has really made me --
it's made all our days.
It's so fun.
-Oh, dude --
-Just watching her climb --
climb all over you.
[ Both laugh ]
-Yeah. No, there's no rules.
I mean, they're -- they're kids,
so the kids are gonna be kids.
-Dad!
-Okay, bud.
-Just let me talk to Jimmy
for a second. Okay.
-Dad?
-Alright, alright.
-What?
-[ Chuckling ] Okay.
Alrighty. Okay.
Alright.
[ Laughter ]
-Dad?
-Got him! Got him!
-Dad!
-Alright.
-Mom!
-Oh, bunny ears.
[ Chuckles ]
-Alright.
-Stop! Ohh!
-[ Laughing ] Okay.
-Oh. Uh, say, guys --
-Okay, okay, everybody back.
Get back there.
Ohh!
-Alright, okay.
-I'm gonna let you go.
I'm gonna let you go, okay, bud?
-Ohh!
[ Laughter ]
-Take care. Um, I'll talk you
to later on, alright?
I'll -- I'll text you.